all right yeah like like Jamie said
we're gonna be talking about
WolframAlpha today brief outline of what
we're going to be talking about we'll do
a brief intro a decent background of
Wolfram Alpha itself and then some of
the features of Wolfram Alpha such as
the step-by-step solutions and the open
code and then some ancillary products
such as the Wolfram problem generator
and Wolfram challenges first off a
little bit about myself my name's Brad
Jaynes I'm the Wolfram Alpha math
Content Manager I've been at Wolfram for
eight years I've been in the math the
Alpha math group for about three years
and I've been the manager for about
three weeks so this is a brand new
position for me but I'm very excited I'm
especially excited to be talking with
and collaborating with some of our users
all right so Wolfram Alpha what what is
Wolfram Alpha wolf's mouth is a
computational knowledge engine and this
little icon here I like it helps break
things down a little bit so Wolfram
Alpha takes uses natural language
understanding so we we interpret what
you type into the search bar convert
that into machine readable language
combine that with our curated data and
knowledge base and use some of our own
dynamic algorithmic computation and
present a a nice result for you we cover
all sorts of different languages it's
primarily in English we're working on
the rest of these languages listed here
in various stages japanese was recently
launched and it's very exciting so
that's from the ground up so we have
natural language understanding in these
languages as well as the output is done
in these languages as well
some some bullet points over fifty
thousand types of algorithms are used in
Wolfram Alpha and the thing I'm most
excited about is all the different
topics that we can cover I am just the
math manager so that's my team works
just in this little sliver but there's
so much more that Wolfram Alpha can do
so this year I've switched through a
browser and I'm on the home page for
Wolfram Alpha is just Wolfram Alpha comm
and here you see that that same icon
that was in my notebook I'm gonna I'm
gonna skip the most popular one I know
it might be controversial well we'll get
to it so let's look at a couple science
and technology examples first one of the
most impressive things I think about
Wolfram Alpha is our our unit system so
we can handle combining converting units
probably better than anyone else in the
world our our unit systems are amazing
so here we're adding 10 miles to 14
kilometers let me zoom in a little bit
and we do this seamlessly we give you
the answer in both kilometers and miles
as well as other potentially interesting
units that we might be curious about
after our kind of expected results that
you're looking for we also give a bunch
of different neat comparisons so hey if
you're thinking about 30 kilometers as a
length
well that is 0.7 times the length of a
marathon or if you're thinking about
that as a height like that is three
times the size of Mount Everest and we
just have more and more information
hopefully some interesting things but
probably some surprising things as well
one thing that I think is really useful
is like for recipes so if you have three
tablespoons
but you are dumb or you're having the
recipe how much is that you know so
three tablespoons of flour but you don't
need that many cookies so oh that's one
and a half tablespoon that's easy but oh
it's also four and a half teaspoons or
this many fluid ounces or this many
milliliters if you're trying to convert
into into metric speaking of metric the
the system is powerful enough and smart
enough to know where you are located so
if I was querying this query from a
country that prefers metric units the
result might be might give me the metric
units first
which i think is really neat let's back
up a little bit and do something else in
the science and tech sphere we also
cover a lot of of different fasteners
and and devices and things like this so
in this industrial standards if you want
to know how coarse or fine a
quarter-inch bolt is we have that for
you we even have a diagram of what the
grooves look like it's it's kind of a
you can get as deep as you want with
this alright let's do a society and
culture example or two we have a huge
database of people and let's just pick
one at random here we have a lot of
their biographical information you know
full names birth death will give you an
image there a timeline of their life a
bunch of noddle notable facts and then
depending on what this person is known
for or we will have specific results for
maybe their particular field so if they
are a musician like this person will
have their
albums and their songs and some of their
hits if they are an actor it will have
their movies if they are a scientist we
might list some of their publications if
they're a politician we will list off
their their various positions that
they've held positions of office family
members other notable facts and Weavin
scrape Wikipedia for some of the
information there
so certain people you can look up their
Wikipedia page history and notice oh his
spiked in what mid 2015 or so and kind
of play a game of like oh why is that
what what happened around then it might
have been I'm not sure what this
particular what the answer to that
particular answer is for this one one
thing that I find very interesting is
our given name data I'm a parent I have
two kids it was really fun exploring the
popularity of particular names when we
were thinking about what to name our
children so we here we can see Steven as
a given name is the two hundred and
seventy first popular most popular given
name for us births we can kind of see a
fraction of what years the name was more
or less popular and then an estimated
age distribution for people with the
given name Steven or whatever else name
you you want to use so it looks like
Steven most Stevens are 40 to 60 there's
a few younger and a few older and some
notable Stevens and and even the meaning
of the word alternate versions of the
name it's pretty neat all right
and again I'm just kind of picking a few
examples almost at random here there's
so much more if you're into sports we
have a ton of sports information all
right so let's go back and look at a
couple math examples looks like
everyone's interested in advanced math
so when I think of advanced math I think
of calculus um so let's do a derivative
here you don't need any the most
impressive thing about Wolfram Alpha to
me is that you don't need any special
programming language you can just type
out your equation your problem however
you think feels the most natural to you
and we're going to do our best to
interpret that and and compute a
wonderful result for you so here we just
typed out derivative of X to the fourth
times sine of X so we didn't even put x
in here although we could have and it
should still recognize what we're trying
to say our natural language parsing is
amazing so here we get the derivative
and the right hand side here shows what
the derivative is we can plot that we
show you what the plot looks like we
give you some alternate forms of the
derivative and we'll even give you some
roots other properties of that
derivative expansions and then other
computations of the from based on the
input that you are asking about so you
know integrals or series expansions or
or what-have-you
one thing that's really nice is say you
wanted to compute the derivative and
then you wanted to see more information
about that you can just click
the answer there and it'll do the
Wolfram Alpha query for that result and
here you see some of the same graph some
of the same alternate forms you could
you can do more things with this you can
say well I'm curious about what the
value of this is at a point so I can say
add x equals two
I missed the X at x equals two and it
will evaluate it for you I'll give you a
nice closed form and a plot highlighting
the point and the value of that point
okay
let's scoot back and do another couple
examples some of our limits are really
neat so we can do you know same kind of
thing you will do the limit we can do
right-handed left-handed limits or total
limits and you know for this particular
case we can see that the limit does not
exist because the limit from the left
and from the right are different and
we'll highlight that on the plot for you
sums product series all sorts of stuff
okay so back to my presentation here
there's been kind of like a background a
basic example of what Wolfram Alpha can
do but I suspect that a lot of people
here are interested in our step-by-step
solutions step by step is probably one
of our most popular features and the
goal of step by step is to show not just
how to do a problem but how how a human
studying this subject at this level
would do this problem
so we we're not going to show
you know number theoretical topics for
arithmetic we're gonna show something
that someone who's learning arithmetic
in elementary school would be able to
follow so if you guys check out my
notebook after the presentation there's
a lot of good links throughout to some
of our examples pages or some of the
marketing pages but I want to show off
some Wolfram Alpha step-by-step examples
so for any any query that has
step-by-step examples and you might have
noticed earlier you'll see this big
colorful button here we like to
highlight how how neat we are with our
step by step so this is just a
polynomial we didn't ask it to do we
didn't ask Wolfram Alpha to do anything
special with this so you query a
polynomial we'll do all sorts of
different things we'll plot it will give
alternate forms we'll solve it for X and
we'll give a number line and for this
particular example the solutions pod has
a step by step button so we can click
that and see what this looks like so
first of all it pops up it's nice and
colorful and we've got first thing you
see we have it's step by step but we
give step one here what you can do is
you can click through step by step and
you will get hints about what the next
step will be and then factor the
left-hand side okay you can click the
next step and you can see what the the
result of that hint would be so if we
factored the left-hand side of this
previous equation this is what we would
get then we can continue stepping
through you know separate the equations
solve the one equation 4x
look at the second equation solve it for
X and then that would be our solution
which matches the solutions found here
if I go back to this step button you'll
see in this top right-hand corner we
have alternate methods so not only do we
show one particular method but we try
and show all of the methods that make
sense for each particular problem so
here we have completing the square or
using the quadratic formula we also try
and sort these methods in a way that
makes sense so the easiest or shortest
steps would be first and then the more
complicated or you know formulaic would
be shown later if you want to skip going
through step by step we also have this
show all steps button and that gives all
the steps all at once so you can scroll
all the way down to find the answer
so steps for things like solutions and
things like derivatives and integrals
steps for those things make sense
because there are there are certain
algorithms that we we use as people that
we learn in school there's certain
algorithms that we use to solve a
particular type of problem so solving
factoring or solving you know how to
compute the average of a list of numbers
but there's some things that are a
little more esoteric like proofs where
there's not necessarily a a particular
algorithm that we always follow but we
still have steps for things like proofs
and I think this is very exciting so
here is a more complicated math concept
so prove that 3 n quantity factorial is
always greater than 3 to the n times n
factorial cubed we're wanting to prove
this by induction that was what the
query asked for so the result is that it
is true for an
if n is an integer and is greater than
zero and we can click the step by step
and see what the steps look like for
that so if you are familiar with
mathematical induction first we
determine the base case we find a
proposition we substitute in and compute
the inductive step and you'll see that
though the steps are complicated we have
fourteen individual steps for this
particular case we eventually do come to
a conclusion and we we show that this
the conjecture is true it's very very
neat that we can do step by step proofs
some of the other interesting step by
step programs that we have are also down
here at the bottom of this examples page
step by step chemistry we can show you
give in a chemical equation we can try
and balance it so to see how glucose and
oxygen react in to water and carbon
dioxide you know how many molecules of
each would be required to balance that
and then we have step by step for this
we didn't look at any chemistry things
here earlier so I'll just scroll down to
see some of the other really neat things
that we can do with chemical equation
queries lots of different properties
that we get there and computation of the
equilibrium constant as well and then a
lot of our formulas I think I really
need two formulas are things that you
would expect to see step-by-step work
with and we we do have a lot of formulas
in Wolfram Alpha so let me just show
this one off real quick here a lot of
the formulas we we have like if we know
the formula it's really easy to plug it
in the values of the each variable that
we know about and then compute the
remaining variables and again here's
where Wolfram Alpha is a great unit
system comes into play so we can compute
numerical units and simplify them and
recognize that Oh kilograms meter
squared per second squared is the same
thing as joules so we can just convert
to a more commonly used unit all right
so that's a lot of step-by-step examples
let's see were there any I think we
looked at some of each of the ones let's
look at an integration one just because
that's probably what people want to see
based on the pole okay so here again is
our integration an example of an
integration result we have since the
query was just integrate some stuff we
kind of infer that they're wanting since
there's only one variable in here that
we're wanting to integrate with respect
to X so we kind of do that implicit
assumption and they don't give any
limits so it doesn't look like a
definite integral but if you scroll down
to the bottom here you will see that we
kind of pick some definite integrals to
show that we think might be interesting
based on what what type of query this is
but let's look at the step by step here
all right so it looks like this one will
be a simple u substitution where we plug
in we pick a u we plug in and we
simplify back out there are other
integrals where we would use different
methods it's it depends on what the
integral is and we also have integrals
for we have we have steps for definite
integrals as well and so here looks like
a more similar u substitution but then
we have an additional step where we are
computing the value of that integral at
the limits to find our answer okay so
yeah there's there's alternate methods
there's oh one more thing I wanted to
show about the steps there's a good
example maybe this one
I kind of skipped over that that's a
complicated looking result
so even even integrals where we have
parameters and things we can still
compute those as well so again a longer
step-by-step result but quite impressive
I think let's see let me do one more
linear algebra example and then we can
move on if we have a section for that
and if we don't I can just pick one all
right so let's do a matrix and see what
we got here so I just typed in a matrix
again I didn't type in what we want to
see done with it
so we give kind of some some basic
example like oh it's a three by three
matrix but that as we scroll down we
have a lot of properties that we can
compute on a matrix and look each one of
these at least most of them have their
own step by step button so everything as
from something as simple as the trace of
the matrix which leaves just adding the
diagonal elements down to characteristic
polynomial the eigenvalues eigenvectors
there's a lot that we do here so let's
look at this eigen values one and see
all their steps here
we are subtracting the identity matrix
times a parameter and then trying to
take the determinant of that and then
once we take the determinant we solve
for that parameter and the solutions of
it turns out to be our eigen values you
might have noticed there's a new button
inside of here and this is one of the
newest parts of the step by step
solutions for Wolfram Alpha we have this
show intermediate steps button so if
you're computing the eigenvalues of
matrix chances are you know how to
compute the derivative however since we
can also show steps for the derivative
we wanted to have a way so that somebody
could click on this and see what those
steps are so here there's a intermediate
steps section so that we can we can show
off some of the steps for how to compute
determinants before we get back to our
finishing up the steps for the
eigenvalues and you'll see these
intermediate steps icons show up all
throughout the step by step
functionality of the website all right
well that's a lot of examples but we
don't have a ton of time so let me try
and get to the rest of my presentation
here another newer thing since actually
almost two years old here is this open
code open code is is kind of a fun thing
that makes use of our our Wolfram cloud
functionality so I'm just going to go
back to this same example here and click
on this open code button there's this
little icon shows that any of these pods
with this icon will be reflected in this
open code page that we're clicking on
here
so if you click on that you will be sent
to a Wolfram cloud document this is the
the cloud version of our Wolfram lang
notebooks are Mathematica notebooks so
all of the all of the pods in Wolfram
Alpha that had that little icon are now
represented in a in an interactive
notebook that you can play with on the
cloud so if you're familiar with
Mathematica you come in here you can do
shift-enter and you can see what
Mathematica does for all of these types
of inputs and you can kind of compare
and contrast sometimes what Mathematica
does is slightly different than what
Wolfram Alpha does for various reasons
like here there's no nullity function in
the Wolfram language so the input that
we have to compute that is a bit longer
than you would expect but we do have a
characteristic polynomial Wolfram
language symbol and we can use that to
compute very easily so yeah these if if
you haven't played with the Wolfram
cloud note books at all there are a lot
of fun these are fully interactive so
you can do your own computations and you
know they're very powerful as you can
see with large numbers and all the
things that you know that Wolfram Alpha
is or that Wolfram Alpha or the Wolfram
language are good at um the Wolfram
cloud notebooks are are useful for those
types of computations as well so that's
a newer feature that I like to highlight
so yeah Wolfram Alpha has a few sister
products that make use of some of the
powerful technologies that are used
behind the scenes at Wolfram Alpha one
of those is the Wolfram problem
generator this is a an online tool
show it off here you can use to generate
random questions in a particular domain
almost you can think of it almost like
the inverse of a Wolfram Alpha query so
when Wolfram Alpha you are asking the
system a question and Wolfram Alpha
tries it's best to come up with an
answer and interesting other information
based on your question in the Wolfram
problem generator well from the Wolfram
Alpha system is asking you a question
and asking you to try to solve it so
let's look at some easy ones that I can
do on the spot here without embarrassing
myself this is the type of thing that
you might see on a quiz or something so
let's see multiply 5 & 4 what if I typed
in 21 if I get a question incorrect
the the system will give me a hint this
hint might look familiar it's very
similar to our hints that we use in me
step by step functionality and then if I
get it correct it'll mark it correct and
we'll move on and you can type in your
answers however you want because the
answer box here makes use of our the the
Wolfram Alpha parser so it knows that
the word 2 spelled out like that is the
same as the integer 2 and it should be
able to count that as correct as well
might refresh it's being a little slow
right now where we can try a different
problem type there so yeah 3 spelled out
like that is correct
if you're really having trouble with a
problem oh it's not 5 maybe it's 51 no
well I
just don't know I give up so type three
oh if you get the problem wrong three
times in a row will pop up the
step-by-step solution for you so you can
try and step through and see where you
went wrong when you were trying to do
this problem so again it's not just
arithmetic although our arithmetic stuff
is really well done we have number
theory algebra calculus linear algebra
statistics and a lot more to come so
let's look at some of this higher math
stuff that everyone seems to be
interested in use substitution so here
we're in the U substitution category so
we know we know that we're practicing
use substitution steps so we can look at
this problem and try and figure out what
would be the best the best way to
approach it
using U substitution and we can we can
do that and again if we're getting it
wrong we can see the the steps you can
also scroll down and see a history of
the problems that you've done previously
or you can generate a random problem
sheet and this could be used to for
example if you are a teacher you can
print out a random problem sheet and
give this to your students and you can
see we even have an answer key here so
you can see you know print out like
refresh this page you can get new
problems and and you can see what you
know how well your students are doing
let's see
all right so that's that's the problem
generator like I said it's it's a
product for about five years and we are
really pushing to improve it as we go
forward yeah we just have a ton of
different types of problems and if you
are an educator you might be interested
in so scrolling down on this main page
we kind of see the problems based on the
topic but we also have these problems
sorted by the common core standards
which is a an educational standard for
the United States so you can click on
you know whether you're in elementary
school or particular grade and you can
see like the actual standards and what
they are and a description of those
standards and then click on that and
then you can try some problems that
would test you on those standards or
test your students on those standards
okay let's move on to the wolfram
challenges this is another kind of
sister product of Wolfram Alpha it's
more focused on some of the few Wolfram
language programming challenges it's
kind of a project Euler type thing so
let's check that out this also makes use
of our cloud notebooks and you can look
at a basic example you can you can
download these to your your own computer
or you can try them in the cloud so yeah
this is fine so what these are are kind
of bite-sized challenges so once you are
getting used to say you're a super user
of Wolfram Alpha and Wolfram Alpha Pro
and you use the open cloud a lot and the
open cloud has introduced you a bit to
the language if you want to get better
at the language or
more experience with the language you
can come to the challenges site to help
challenge yourself to be more more
familiar with the Wolfram language so
here this particular challenge is
looking for lengths character lengths of
various Roman numerals so the numbers 1
through 5 the longest Roman numeral is
not the largest one it happens to be in
this case 3 so the length of the largest
Roman numeral by character count is 3
and that's what this challenge is asking
you to try to compute there's a lot of
interactivity built into the Wolfram
challenge system so we we will
automatically grade you tell you if
you're correct or not and then there's a
bunch of different types of factors that
we we test your particular solution to
these problems on and there is a global
leader board for all of the Wolfram
challenges that we have so feel free to
to come check out some of the Wolfram
challenges try and get on the leader
board you can even submit your own
challenges if you have a good idea for a
short programming challenge like this ok
so that's pretty much it for me I've
I've talked about Wolfram Alpha
specifically this step by step
functionality a little bit of the open
code the the problem generator the
Wolfram problem generator and Wolfram
challenges please feel free to check out
my presentation notebook there's a lot
of links a lot of stuff we didn't cover
and in such a time this last page is
just some of these are more related than
others the elementary introduction to
the Wolfram language is a wonderful tool
if you are trying to learn how to do
anything in Mathematica or the Wolfram
language
there's documentation so in more recent
versions of the Wolfram language there's
a Wolfram Alpha function built-in that
does some of basically the open code
stuff where we compute or change your
Wolfram Alpha type input into a
mathematical function we kind of
duplicate what what Wolfram Alpha does
inside your own local notebook the
pricing and information about the
Wolfram Alpha Pro is here as well some
Wolfram community form groups